sont ils rêvaient d'une autre guerre
sous d'autres climats en turquie les
allemands construit une voie ferrée le
chemin de fer de bagdad
le kayser veut ainsi prendre pied en
orient à travers les balkans
cet axe d' influence croiser
malheureusement la route vitale de la
russie vers la méditerranée des alliés
le point de rencontre c'est le détroit
des dardanelles gardé par la péninsule
turc de gallipoli et au delà par
constantinople
la capitale de la dynastie des ottomans
est sur le déclin
enfermé de 5 le dernier sultan à des
fonctionnaires corrompus et doit faire
face à des jeunes révolutionnaires
nationaliste il abandonne le pouvoir à
un de ces jeunes turcs
voici en verre pacha il a 33 ans et des
conseillers militaires pour chiens ceux
ci sont tout à fait heureux d'être au
soleil loin de verdun cette coterie
d'experts et deux militaires allemands
et dirigé par l'iman vente 100 m
ils organisent l'entrée en guerre de la
turquie aux côtés de l'allemagne
naturellement
29 octobre 1914 deux croiseurs allemands
déjà le gueut bonne et le breslau
battant pavillon turc avait pénétré dans
la mer noire il bombardait les ports
russes pour churchill il fallait libérer
la route de dessins et prendre les
détroits il est difficile disait balfour
pourtant prudent imaginez une opération
qui donne plus d'espoir mais pour
prendre les détroits il fallait prendre
cali poli
mars 1915 l'armada alliés s'avance vers
les détroits il faut prendre
constantinople ouvrir un second front
pour établir un contact avec l'allié
russe
et si l'on peut attaquer l'allemagne par
le sud
encore faut-il prendre les dardanelles
et neutraliser les canons croupe de
gallipoli qui un mois auparavant ont
déjà défié les alliés
les champs de mines et les tirs
d'artillerie son meurtrier le cuirassé
français le bouvet cool en deux minutes
le gaulois et neutralisé trois navires
anglais sont touchés et navire ne
peuvent pas franchir les dardanelles en
force
il faut les conquérir en débarquant
à londres on s'inquiète un haut lieu des
chances de succès de l'opération des
dardanelles winston churchill premier
lord de l'amirauté décident de forcer
les dardanelles à tout prix
il obtient les moyens de transporter les
soldats de fischer premier lors de la
mer qui s'arrange pour trouver des
navires en nombre suffisant le ministre
de la guerre leur questionnaire a donné
son accord et fournit les effectifs
nécessaires au conseil le premier
ministre herbert catastrophe se rallie
au projet de churchill
les dés sont jetés les alliés
débarqueront au dardanelles déjà les
troupes anglaises et françaises se
concentrent et s'entraîne en egypte les
sénégalais les légionnaires rejoignent
les indiens les néo zélandais et les
australiens
les amis organisent des bases dans les
îles proches d'un brossé de télé dos et
s'apprête à affronter la terrible
péninsule qu'ils ne connaissent que par
des guides achetés dans les bazars
d'égypte le moral des attaques est au
plus haut
les alliés sont 80 milles dont dix sept
mille français
un curieuse état d'esprit règne parmi
eux une sorte d'exaltation a justifié il
se croit vainqueur les turcs sont
formidablement retranché disposant de
canons lourds
les alliés du nord c'est la fièvre de
gallipoli une maladie purement mentale
au début de l'opération
la guerre au soleil dans un décor de
rêve la méditerranée le sable des plages
les hommes dont la folie en tête
la fièvre de la gallipoli dieu je n'ai
jamais été aussi heureux je réalise
soudain que l'ambition de ma vie a été
de participer à une expédition militaire
contre constantine ap
celui qui parle ainsi est un poète
anglais rapporte bloc roquemaure a
empoisonné peu après dans une île de
méditerranée avant le début des
opérations il ne prendra pas en stantina
up
les français participent ils lancent un
commando de fusiliers-marins sur la côte
asiatiques
c'est un bluff pour détourner
l'attention des turcs de l'aso principal
contre gallipoli
et
trois semaines seulement de préparation
l'expédition se rassemblent dans les
îles des bases ont été installés les
hommes s'impatiente sous les tentes
blanches de lemnos oudin bros où ils
attendent une flotte très nombreuses
cette flotte c200 navire qui transporte
75 mille hommes sans comptait 1600
chevaux et mulets et puis les tonnes de
caisses de munitions et de vivres de
fruits et légumes frais pour éviter la
dysenterie
à
24 avril 1915 la force d'invasion a pris
la mer
les chefs d'angolais sont inquiet il se
demande si les unités d'assaut ne vont
pas se heurter à un mur de feu
que vont faire les turcs le vice-amiral
sorte jaune dorée beck qui commande la
flotte de débarquement et les unités
d'escort n'est pas responsable des
troupes de terre toutes ses unités de
débarquement sont commandés par ian
hamilton un vieux camarade de kitsch
nerfs les troupes d'assaut sont tous
made sort et le maire enter weston pour
les britanniques
deux soeurs williams board woods pour
les âmes
les français sont sous les ordres du
général damade
ces soldats français doivent conduire
les attaques de diversion en asie et au
nord de la zone
les deux vrais assauts seront menées par
les anglais sur cali poli parlez-en à
qu'un peu plus loin au nord-est
winston churchill devait plus tard
convenir qu'un assaut donné de plein
fouet contre les défenses pourvu d'armes
modernes et en abondance était une vraie
folie une folie dont il devait porter la
responsabilité
gallipoli ferme les dardanelles il faut
enlever la position coûte que coûte à
l'aube du 25 avril 1915 les troupes
d'assaut s'apprête à bondir sur les
cibles hâtivement repérer et dont on
ignore la capacité de résistance
sur le rivage les turcs sont parfois
surpris mais ils sont en général fort
bien préparés au choc le rivage et
difficile d'accès et puis il ya les
erreurs d'appréciation commise par le
commandement allié un défaut de
communication entre les unités qui ne
débarque pas toujours à l'endroit prévu
les australiens et néo zélandais saute à
terre tombe par centaines sous le feu
turcs mais réussit à prendre pied
au cap et laisse mes passagers des
bateaux de débarquement sont tous
touchés avant même d'arriver sur la
plage au nord les en zac sont débarqués
à un mille de leurs objectifs au pied de
falaise inaccessible il charge dans un
feu d'enfer
m
les troupes d'assaut tentent de
s'emparer des auteurs et les renforts
arrivent sur la plage déjà à présent
combrée la division bayou française
débarque avec 8 division anglaise contre
les turcs il faut s'enterrer pour tenir
au moins les plages et quelques points
d'appui au jeu les turcs lancé par
l'iman vanders attaquants n'ont pour les
français qui ne sont là que pour tromper
l'ennemi
il rend fort anglais les empêche de
progresser oblige globalement reculé un
chef énergique le colonel mustapha kemal
sauve la situation en disant à ses
soldats
je ne vous ordonne pas d'attaqué je vous
ordonne mourir mais personne n'ose
discuter un arbre de mustafa kemal
leur objectif est une crête qui commande
toute la partie sud de la péninsule de
gallipoli les turcs creusent des
tranchées autour des auteurs
pour tenir ce point crucial les alliés
creuse en contrebas la partie n'est pas
égal
le nouveau front de gallipoli l'exotique
devient la répétition du front de
champagne
les armées sont enterrés il y fait très
chaud les chevaux ont soif et aussi des
hommes girondeau du 176e d'infanterie
saute sur un cheval et plonge en mer
pour se rafraîchir au mépris des balles
à cap et los andes saint-claud vol sur
un minuscule jambes bataille
vingt mille hommes sont déjà morts ou
blessés le corps expéditionnaire néo
zélandais et australien a beaucoup
souffert
les français comptent aussi beaucoup de
victimes
les renforts de la division bayod sont
épuisés ils tombent comme des mouches
sur la plage elle même
l'un d'entre eux jérôme carcopino a
décrit mieux que personne n'en faire des
dardanelles
à paris on ignorer le sacrifice de ces
malheureux
vous
à gallipoli de nouveau c'était l'impasse
les troupes languissent dans la chaleur
de la méditerranée la monotonie des
jours la prostration la malaria la
dysenterie la dengue une grippe virale
qui tue plus sûrement que les turcs 145
1000 tués ou blessés d'année dardanelles
dealer fischer elles seront notre
tombeau
à londres
fischer premier lors de la maire
démissionne
il accuse churchill dans une lettre
secrète d'avoir conduit l'angleterre au
désastre par une appréciation héros mais
les chances d'une expédition
le chef du parti conservateur bonar law
averti le gouvernement qu'ils exigent la
démission de john gill les dardanelles
ont flanqué le cabinet par terre
churchill ordonne afficheur de rester
fischer lui des voulait à tout prix
force et des dardanelles et rien ne vous
fera renoncer
je vous connais si bien vous resterez et
je m'en irai ils s'en vont tous les deux
le premier ministre à swift accorde
autorise la tête de churchill pendant
six mois celui ci certes en france en
uniforme
il sait il n'en finirons jamais dit-il
en partant kitchener et ébranlé la
décision lui appartient
envoyez des renforts à gallipoli ou
abandonnés il décide de monter nouvelle
attaque le public ignore tout de la
situation désespérée dans les détroits
la campagne pour le recrutement est
accélérée en angleterre
en juin juillet 1915
les anglais envoient encore cinq
divisions soit cinquante mille hommes
pour renforcer leurs huit divisions
et nouveaux venus n'ont subi aucun
entraînement spécial avec 120 mille âmes
le général ian hamilton est priée de
transformer le désastre en victoire
c'est la dernière chance de l'expédition
une attaquante die à partir d'un à kobe
d'une nouvelle plage de débarquement un
peu plus loin au nord à suivre la bi les
deux forces doivent se rejoignent briser
la péninsule et s'assurer des auteurs
la date de l'attaqué fixée au 6 août
surprise complète à suivre la paix les
turcs laisse faire mais les officiers
reprenne en main avec de l'artillerie de
campagne et des mitrailleuses
ils empêchent la progression des vingt
mille soldats anglais
ces anglais ne sont pas tous envoyé à
l'assaut en même temps beaucoup se
baignent doivent leur tes attentes des
ordres sur la plage les ordres ne ris
pas les généraux sont vieux et it or la
baie souffla retombe dans la trachée
inertie des autres plages n'étaient les
rafales de mitrailleuse ou les salves
d'artillerie français anglais peuvent se
croire en vacances
exploitant ce désordre mustafa kemal a
réuni des renforts et donne l'ordre d'
attaque
les alliés perdre 40 mille hommes en dix
jours les turcs 40000 aussi les blessés
sont si nombreux que des yachts privés
viennent de grande-bretagne pour les
enlever
selon le mot d'un général les alliés ont
gagné seulement 500 acres de mauvais
pâturages
toujours la censure pour cacher le
désastre un correspondant de reuter et
tellement surveillé qu'il ne peut voir
que quelques mètres de plage est lisse
ashmeade bartlett reportait au daily
telegraph exige son retour en angleterre
que son reportage soit publié un
journaliste australien keith murdoch
écrite un squeeze pour condamner la
campagne et demandé qu'on arrête le
massacre trop d'anglais troubles néo
zélandais d'indiens de français de
sénégalais sont morts pour ces arpents
de sable méditerranéen
m
le 15 octobre 1915 femmes elton est
rappelé par kitchener sur une forte
pression du gouvernement
il abandonne son armée en décomposition
qui souffre de tous les maux possibles
sur les plages de gallipoli il est
remplacé par le lieutenant général
charles monroe à sévère officiers du
front ouest
il n'est plus question de forcer les t3
le rêve de churchill s'écroule ça tâché
d'évacuer à tout prix gallipoli en
novembre qui cheney revient en personne
visitée ce front les routes khartoum et
de la guerre des boers 1,6
courageusement au dernier acte avec un
sang-froid tout le britannique
ils organisent l'évacuation des forces
aux alliés de gallipoli huit mois
d'enfer cinq cent mille soldats perd 2
dont la moitié seront tués ou blessés
les autres morts de maladie
un dernier mirent à craon possible
évacuation sous les canons turc 118
mille hommes sont soufflées par un seul
et perdu pas à se mêler c'est sur les
plages
c'est le plus éclatant succès d'une
expédition désastreuse
il était malheureusement trop claire au
moment où commencer l'atroce massacre de
verdun que l'ouverture d'un second front
était une illusion
les allemands ont décidé de faire face
aux situations nouvelles créées au sud
de l'europe vers l'automne 1915
ils peuvent compter sur leurs propres
armes et sur quelques unités
autrichienne et sur les bulgares qui
sont entrés dans la guerre
il dispose de très solide unité d'un
armement lourd en calant krupp et d'une
longue habitude de la guerre contre
leurs voisins balkaniques
le bloc des puissances centrales est
désormais constituée allemagne autriche
hongrie bulgarie et la turquie
le général von mac and then est chargé
du commandement n'aurions il le partage
avec un autre général que les français
connaissent bien
eric falque nine qui commandait et qui a
échoué 1,1 cette armée doit s'ouvrir la
route de constantinople qui ne peut être
qu'une route de terre parce que les
alliés etienne la mer un obstacle
pourtant sur le parcours la nation serbe
farouchement hostile aux puissances
centrales
c'est une évidence stratégique aux yeux
de fall kane
la serbie doit sauter le roi pierre de
serbie et vieux malade mais résolue son
fils le régent alexandre a été éduqué en
russie tsariste leur premier ministre
est un vieil homme pas schiste qui a
programmé la guerre des serbes contre
les austro hongrois détester lempire
d'autriche hongrie a voulu par deux fois
écrasé la serbie il n'y a pas réussi et
il brûle de recommencer
non
cette fois des moyens très importants
sont mises en jeu la serbie est à feu et
à sang les villes sont détruites par les
bombes les villages incendiés
l'armée royale et impériale d'autriche
hongrie néglige rien pour raser le pays
les chefs envisage une retraite le long
de la mer pour échapper aux autrichiens
et aux allemands et aussi aux bulgares
qui veulent leur part de gâteau les
serbes jure de revenir pour former leurs
camps royaume des serbes des croates et
des slovènes
en attendant les autrichiens avance
occupent le pays slaves
suivent le cours des rivières le danube
la morava la serbie disent les
autrichiens est un serpent qu'il faut
écraser
les serbes sont en retraite
une armée de deux cent mille âmes recul
en ordre tinchant de sauver ces
bataillons pack transport pas de vivre
les munitions l'armée traîne avec elle
une centaine de canon et 24000
autrichien prisonniers le vieux roi est
en voiture un peu entraîne dans une
chaise à porteurs le chef de l'armée qui
souffre la marche dure longtemps très
longtemps
deux mois de marche beaucoup perdent
leurs chaussures dans la neige
boncourt les pieds gelés d'autres
meurent de froid dans cette retraitée
roic on mange les chevaux les villageois
suivent les soldats pour ne pas tomber
aux mains des bulgares la retraite
héroïque des serbes c'est un peu
l'équivalent de la retraite des belges
en août 14 et le roi des serbes
ressemble singulièrement au roi
chevalier le roi de belgique la retraite
des serbes
c'est un peu le fantôme de la nation
oh
les serbes essaye de gagner à travers
les montagnes la frontière grecque où
ils sont sûrs d'être bien accueillies la
grèce n'est pas belligérantes mais elle
est amicale et les alliés combattants à
salonique
malheureusement les serbes cherche enfin
une mission allier ils en trouvent pas
et doivent gagner les montagnes
d'albanie vers l'ouest peut être
trouveront ils les alliés dans le port
de durazzo ils y sont mais pour
embarquer toute l'armée serbe il n'y a
que quelques bateaux on les emmène tout
de même dans l'île de corfou 70000 sont
morts en chemin cent quarante mille
survivent souvent bien amaigri ou
malades ils sont enfin secourus et
soigné encadré pour repartir au combat
à salonique ils veulent se battre au
plus tôt ils ont leur patrie à
reconquérir
mon
non
l'armée de salonique est une tour de
babel on y parle toutes les langues de
la coalition des alliés dans le port les
transports de troupes
les cargos amène sans arrêt des renforts
du matérial du ravitaillement au risque
d'être torpillé en méditerranée par les
sous marins allemands les italiens après
l'entrée en guerre de leur pays ont
rejoint les alliés les serbes arrivent
les russes sont déjà là les grecs on est
volontaire car le roi des grecs hésitent
à entrer dans le conflit a quitté la
position très avantageuse pour lui de la
neutralité
les alliés sont à la fois ses invités
ses otages
quand le président de la république
raymond poincaré habillé en chauffeur à
son habitude visite la base il trouve
une armée internationale très bien
organisée qui veut percer dans les
balkans selon le vieux rêve de torture
il n'y a malheureusement pas de vue
stratégique précise pour cette armée les
serbes sont seuls motivés ils veulent
reconquérir leur pays vallée après
vannes et en franchissant les montagnes
ils veulent créer la yougoslavie cet
objectif l'armée de salonique
l'acceptent
elle mettra deux ans pour l'atteindre un
autre front stagnant vient d'être créée
ici à salonique
si le front d'orient donne quelques
satisfactions aux alliés il piétine sur
celui de salonique
quant aux italiens ils entre-temps caire
seulement le 24 mai 1915 les foules
italiennes sont mobilisés dans un
enthousiasme relatif la propagande de
guerre est animée surtout par les
nationalistes gabriel et danone sur par
exemple à des combattants les plus
patriotes c'est benito mussolini
le socialiste dur hier pacifiste devenu
furieusement nationaliste les alliés ont
fait à l'italie des promesses
ils ont acheté son entrée en guerre ils
y ont concédé par avance des territoires
pris à l'ancienne autriche-hongrie
essentiellement dans l'adriatique
le parlement italien a voté la guerre
après une longue période d'hésitation
les italiens sont devenus guerrier jadis
partenaires des allemands et des
autrichiens dans ma triple alliance de
bismarck
ils ont changé leur veste quant au
gouvernement de vienne il est bien
décidé à contenir les revendications
italienne sur les villes slave de la
côte sur les îles de dalmat c est peut
être même sur le tyrol du sud
voilà donc les alpes à l'est vers
saglier en faction sur les pics des âmes
une guerre épuisante sur des piques
glacée qui demande aux soldats des
sacrifices quotidiens
ils doivent traîner des canons sur leurs
épaules dans la haute montagne
sept officiers observent à la jumelle
une petite ville italienne qui devait
plus tard être le lieu d'un désastre
qu'a par un taux
la flotte italienne a pour mission de
surveiller l'adriatique et d'empêcher
les navires autrichien le quitter leur
base de paul là où il dispose pourtant
de plusieurs unités lourdes renforcés de
sous marins allemands 6 sous-marins sont
acheminés par voie ferrée est remonté
sur place le premier champ de bataille
et le trentin deux larges valait yantai
les ânes
les autrichiens il ans quatre divisions
expérimentés qui l'ont retirée du front
russe
avec 2000 canons lourds de conception
récente
le général italien cas dorna est
convaincu que les montagnes sont sa
meilleure protection est que les
autrichiens n'attaqueront pas deux de
ses quatre armes et s'étire sur un front
de 150 km cas dorna n'a pas bonne
réputation auprès des officiers généraux
allaient y est bon stratège mais mauvais
tacticien il n'est pas économe de la vie
de ces hommes
il est moins encore quand les
autrichiens attaque en 1916 avec toute
la puissance de leur artillerie de
montagne
pour
en moins d'avoir les italiens sont
chassés de leurs positions et se
retrouve 20 km en arrière dans le plus
grand désarroi
heureusement pour kde orma broussilov
attaque dans l'est et les autrichiens
doivent retirer quatre divisions du
franc du trentin ils ont d'ailleurs du
mal à approvisionner leurs fronts en
raison des routes étroites et de
l'épuisement de leurs productions de
guerre les italiens retrouvent donc leur
position antérieure au prix de lourdes
pertes
145 mille morts blessés et disparus
contre 80 milles autrichien seulement
après le trentin cas dorna un deuxième
champ de bataille celui de lise en saut
qui courent sur 100km cadors ma veut
prendre gorizia sur la route de trieste
pour les italiens trieste est un
objectif mythiques comme strasbourg pour
les français adorent masse dépense sans
compter plus de 12 bataille terrifiante
meurtrière où les hommes tombent par
milliers ils doivent remporter chaque
colline escaladé dans le plus grand
péril des pics l'un après l'autre pour
se retrouver sur le plateau désertique
de carso où les vents hurlant matt des
pierres aussi pointus que des couteaux
chaque au but fait éclater le rocher en
mille éclats mortels
cad orma et puis ils sont armés qui
frappe sans relâche le carso
mortellement froid l'hiver chaud et
paludéens l'été le quart saussez le
gallipoli de cadeaux rne
m
la 6ème bataille du carso a lieu en août
les italiens s'accroche bec et ongles
sur le plateau il creuse aux besoins des
tunnels pour avancer à toute force
avancé sur gorizia
il
pour
les italiens entre dans gorizia mais
aussitôt cadors m'a pris de peur
hésitent à poursuivre sur trieste il
redoute que le commandement autrichien
l'envoi des renforts
les autrichiens contre attaque voilà
qu'à dorment à rejeter sur ces bases de
départ prêt à livrer une 7ème 8ème une
onzième bataille de l'iss au les
adversaires sans terre dans leur ligne
de trancher le front ne bougera plus il
n'y a pas d'échec et mat
mais prisonnier autrichien porte la
tristesse sur le visage ils ont été
battus contre les russes
ils n'ont pas gagné contre les italiens
vienne 21 novembre 1916 l'empereur
françois joseph vient de mourir à l'âge
de 86 ans
il régnait depuis 68 ans les funérailles
sont en tout point conforme aux rituels
moyen-âge les habsbourgs un capucin
implore l'admission au paradis de frère
françois
ce pêcheur sa mort rend les autrichiens
orphelins
le nouvel empereur est un petit neveu
charles à 29 ans il veut bien faire mais
il manque totalement l'expérience et ne
jouit pas de la confiance des allemands
zita son épouse italienne le poussent à
se détourner de l'emprise allemande
charles entame des conversations
secrètes avec les alliés qui
n'aboutissent pas pendant qu'à vienne la
famine s'installe le prix des vives
devient inabordable et la population et
si épuisée qu'elle se montre
dangereusement apathique
e
partout les éclopés du front les blessés
les fantômes effrayant
le pape benoît case prend l'initiative
d'une demande de paix blanche au nom de
l'épuisement des peuples il faut signer
une paix sans annexion revenir au statu
quo mettre fin au carnage
impossible 30 millions d'hommes sont
morts cette démarche du vatican tombe à
l'eau les aliens y donne pas suite
les allemands en grandvaux leurs deux
territoires sont ils disposés à les
restituer
l'autriche hongrie est la meilleure
alliée de l'allemagne puisque la paix
n'est pas possible nouvel empereur
charles demande en italie met du désert
qu'il rencontre à cet effet le kayser
chercher à obtenir des renforts italien
sur le front de l'ouest
il est très déçu d'avoir à voler au
secours de son allié cependant il lui
promet de venir
l'autriche milite il peut compter sur
l'allemagne pour attaquer l'italie
parjure
tout est prêt pour qu'une nouvelle
bataille s'engage avec des renforts
allemands la 12e batal de leeson saut
dans l'histoire elle porte le nom de k
pareto
24 octobre 1917 quatre heures de
bombardement au gaz une heure de
préparation d'artillerie la 14e armée du
général von bülow s'élance avec ses six
divisions allemandes et c9 division
autrichienne elle s'est depuis longtemps
et dans le plus grand secret et préparer
à l'offensive
le plan est de s'emparer du village de
cap au recto un secteur calme à l'écart
du front principal qui permet de tourner
le flanc de l'armée italienne de
l'isoler de l'enfermer dans une nasse et
de descendre ensuite vers la plaine
lumineuse tous les moyens nécessaires
sont réunies la coordination des unités
allemandes et italiennes est assurée
avec fermeté dans tous les cas on attend
l'heure de la tacc avec confiance
en peu de temps le coup de bélier
germanique perce le front italien
le général cadors mahé complètement
surprise ces soldats essaye de soutenir
la violence du feu ennemi
ouais
kapo reto est un désastre
sept cent mille hommes sont rejetées
dans la plaine de lombardie en une
immense cohue qui s'étale sur 120 km 700
mille hommes que l'on parvient à grande
force avec l'aide des conseils de guerre
qui condamne les déserteurs et les
insoumis à organiser sur la pierre leroy
supplie ses troupes de se reprendre
soyez une armée unie ma lâcheté et de la
trahison général qu'à dorna les renvoyer
à juste titre on considère que la
défaite et son oeuvre plus que celle des
soldats
e
la charge des autrichiens s'arrête dans
la plaine il manque désormais
terriblement de munitions leur avance
rapide n'a pas permis aux
approvisionnements de suivre
m
le 10 novembre ils sont sur les rives de
la pierre larivière et de larges
infranchissable à lilongue facilement la
vallée les autrichiens attentes à
plusieurs reprises de la franchir
en vain pendant la bataille les italiens
ne résistez pas sur leur ligne ils
s'enfuyaient en désordre de long des
routes surchargées il jeter leurs
masques à gaz inefficace
ils sortaient de leur tranchée pour se
rendre qu'à dorna avait perdu en une
seule journée
trois cent cinquante mille hommes 270
mines s'était rendu
les prisonniers italien a crié
volontiers et vive l'autriche où venait
à rome ils en avaient assez cette guerre
le patriotisme des débuts avait fait
place à un découragement profond la plus
mauvaise des paies valait mieux que
cette guerre là il avait le sentiment
d'avoir été entraînés dans la guerre par
leurs dirigeants
un ambulancier américain de 19 ans avait
été blessé la bataille il se nommait
hemingway a cure et 26 ans engagé comme
aide sanitaire avait vécu cet enfer il
serait pas plus tard sous le nom de jean
xxiii un jeune lieutenant allemand erwin
rommel s'était distingué dans
l'infanterie le but des alliés étaient
très simplement de maintenir l'italie
dans la guerre il fallait pour cela
envoyez des renforts français
britanniques et même américains à la fin
1917 un visiteur anglais de nobles
prestance de membres en défaut au roi
d'italie
il sollicite un engagement dans l'armée
le roi refuse il ne veut pas d'incidents
diplomatiques sont solliciteurs et le
prince de galles
un pilote américain de 35 ans combattant
italie fiorello la guardia il sera maire
de new york
l'hiver est calme sur le front
terriblement froid mais le printemps est
bientôt là avec les offensives qui
reprennent les autrichiens les allemands
veulent de nouveau père c'est le front
italien même renforcé par les habiller
les autrichiens attaque
en france les allemands attaquent est ce
qu'ils vont gagner la guerre sur la piaf
les autrichiens sont repoussés on attend
la dernière offensive celles des alliés
qui fera exploser lempire d'autriche
hongrie
les italiens l'emportent avec l'aide des
alliés un automne les divisions
allemandes ne sont plus là le guen dorff
les appeler sur le fond de france
l'autriche est en train de s'écrouler
son ar men continue à se battre que pour
tâcher d'obtenir une paix descente